Let us now illustrate, with an
example, the calculations of n
step transition probabilities
that we have just discussed.
In this example, we are given
a two state Markov chain,
and as part of the input,
the one step transition
probabilities between
these two states.
So, given that you
are in state one,
the probability that you will
next go to state two is 0.5,
and the probability that you
will stay in state one is 0.5.
And, given that you
are in state two,
the probability that you will
next go to state one is 0.2,
and the probability that you
will stay in state two is 0.8.
Now, suppose that you
start in state one,
and you would like to calculate
the probability of being
in state one after n
transitions, or after n steps.
With our notation
here, this is r11 of n.
That probability can
happen in two ways.
After n minus 1 steps,
you end up in state one,
and then for the
last transition,
you stay in state one, or after
the first n minus 1 transition,
you end up in
state two, and then
you transition
back to state one.
Assuming that you start
again in state one,
and you would like to calculate
the probability that you end up
in state two after n steps,
you could apply the same logic,
but these are probabilities.
And given that you started
in state one, after n steps,
you will either be in
state one or in state two.
So r12 of n is simply
1 minus r11 of n.
And this system
of two recursions
is enough to propagate
r11 of n and r12 of n
as a function of n.
Let us do it and
fill the blanks here.
As indicated before,
the case for n
equals 0 or n equals 1
are simple and do not
require the use of
the recursions here.
So for example, for n equals
0, r11 of 0 will simply be 1,
and so as a result,
r12 of 0 will be 0.
And again, r22 of 0 will be
1, and as a result, r21 of 0
will be 0.
For n equals 1, these are the
simple one step transition
probabilities.
So you have 0.5
here, and 0.5 here,
and r21 here are 0.2 and 0.8.
The next cases for n equals
2 become more interesting.
So, to reach n equals 2,
r11 of 2, two options again.
You can go this way
with a probability 0.5,
or you can go from that to
here with a probability 0.2.
So here, we obtain total
probability of 0.25, here,
a probability of 0.10,
and when you sum these two
probabilities, you obtain
0.35, which is r11 of 2.
As a result, you get
0.65 for r12 of 2.
Then you can follow the
same process for n equals 3,
n equals 4, et
cetera, et cetera.
I will not do it
here, but this would
be an interesting
exercise for you
to do the next
several steps, perhaps
within an Excel spreadsheet.
But suppose that I tell you
the number for n equals 100
and I tell you that the
number that you obtain here
is about 2/7.
So as a result, the numbers
that you are going to have here
is about 5/7.
Let us then apply this
simple recursion in order
to find the values
here for n equals 101.
r11 of 101 will be 2/7 times
0.5 plus 5/7 times 0.2.
Will be 1/7 for the first one
plus 1/7 for the second one,
and so we obtain again 2/7.
And if you do the
same calculation,
you will end up with 5/7 here.
This is an interesting fact.
When the system
starts in state one,
the probability that I
find myself in state one
after a long period
of time seems
to converge to a constant
value, in that case,
to the constant value of 2/7.
Assume now that you want to do
the same calculation for r21
and r22.
In other words, you
start in state two
and you are
interested in knowing
the evolution of these
r21 of n and r22 of n
as a function of n.
Again, I will let you do
it, but I can tell you
that these
probabilities will also
seem to converge to a
constant, and in fact,
will converge to something
that is exactly the same, 2/7
here and 5/7 here.
This is a second
interesting fact.
Irrespective of where we
started, either from state one
or from state two, the
probability of being in a state
one after a long
period of time seems
to converge to the
same constant, 2/7.
So in some sense, for
that particular example,
the importance of
the initial state
vanishes as time
goes by and does not
influence long
term probabilities
of being in any
of the two states.
Note that this is not true
at the beginning starting
at state two.
The picture, after
a few transitions,
will look different than if
you had started from state one.
So the initial state does tell
you something at the beginning,
but this vanishes
as time goes by.
We describe these
convergence properties
by saying that the
Markov chain eventually
enters a steady state.
What does this really mean?
Does it mean that the
state of the Markov
chain itself becomes
steady and eventually stops
at a given place?
No.
The state of the system
will keep jumping forever.
What becomes steady are the
probabilities that describe Xn.
After the Markov chain
enters steady state, then,
at any time, if you take a
photo of the system and ask,
what is the probability that
the chain will be in state one
on that picture, it will be 2/7.
By the way, the steady
state of being in state two
is greater than the steady
state of being in state one.
Does it make sense?
Yes.
State two is a little bit
more sticky than state one
in the following sense.
When you get to state
two, the probability
that you remain in
state two, which is 0.8,
is greater than the
corresponding probability
for state one, which is 0.5.
So to conclude,
this Markov chain
has exhibited some nice
long term properties.
Is this always the case
for any Markov chains?
Let us see.